[موسيقى]
ورقة 1 year Kim Soo-gil مضيعة
أنت لا تعرف أن تمريرة ستينغ لها فينسينت
هذا هو
يريد
حاولت إغلاق البطانية كثيرًا
آه
[موسيقى]
أوو
وو
أنت
أوه نعم
[موسيقى]
نعم
[صفق]
[موسيقى]
4 أوه
اه اه اه اه
[موسيقى]
أوو
محكوم عليه بالاستماع مثل ما يسمى بفركتوز القرع
ليم مين هي التالية التي تعيش حياة جميلة مثل الألوان الزاهية
نعم ، هذا هو Soonyoung الذي لاحظ
منصة واحدة لتشخيص نسبة السكر في الدم
تُظهر الألعاب النارية التي يطلق عليها اسم 3 قبور معرفة مصير الأشخاص المشهورين ، وسماء العاصمة 1
أنا أصبغ عيني
[موسيقى]
وي
جدا
5 لتجمع الإرادة
احفظ الخبز
[موسيقى]
ه
على طريقتها الخاصة
[موسيقى]
لم أتردد في مغازلة سحري
فقط مع الزخم ، جنة الناس على هذه الأرض 2
1 يبدو أن قراءة الانصهار
[موسيقى]
وو
أنا قلق من حوالي 50 مليون إبر أثناء استخدام الملابس
تأكد من زيارة الآلهة التي رآها الناس والآلهة التي دفنت فيها سعادتي.
من حولنا أقدم منافس جون جو مون كومراد كات نحن
مثل Kim Bo-ra ، هذه باقة من الزهرة.
إنها باقة المجتمع ، الجيل الذي سيترك الآباء العظماء وراء 7 تريليون سوني 3
أوو
آه 4
[موسيقى]
الصفة 8 الجميع يشربون الكحول
مبروك لجميع المشاهدين
[موسيقى]
أوو